Hello friends and members of the SumTV
family. You're watching I'd Like to
Know, our Bible question and answer
program here at Secrets Unsealed and Sum
TV. My name is CA Murray. I am
accompanied by to my left, Pastor David
Salazar, who is the general manager of
our Latino channel and our founder and
president, Pastor Steven Boore. Again,
gentlemen, always good to have you here
to study the word of God.
>> Amen.
>> All right, before we get started, we
want to encourage you to write to us
your questions. We'd love to get them
and uh we have some. We would always
like to have more. So you want to write
to tvsums
m as in marytv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
And we promise you we'll get to your
question as quickly as we can. And when
we do, the answer will come from the
word of God. We make you that promise.
Pastor Salazar, would you pray for us as
we begin our question and answers for
this?
>> Absolutely. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, we are coming before
you to uh uh ask that you will grant us
your holy spirit to understand and to be
able to bring to our minds the words
that you have given to us through your
holy scriptures. Allow us Lord to be
able to present answers that are uh
biblically sound that they will bring uh
understanding and light to those who are
searching the truth and that we may not
speak anything of our own selves but
they may be in harmony to you and to
your word. We thank you for this in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question today
comes to us from Laura who is writing to
us from Florida. My question is, what is
the difference between the Hebrew word
nephesh used in Genesis 2:7 to describe
the breath of life that God gave Adam
and the Hebrew word ruak as used in
Ecclesiastes 12:7 as the spirit that
goes back to God when we die and the
dust goes back to the ground. If they
were exactly the same thing, why are
there two different words with two
different meanings used? If we are to
understand and tell others that dust
plus breath equals soul and soul minus
breath equal dust, to explain there is
no conscious conscience uh conscience
part of us that goes straight to God
when we die. I think we need to
reconcile these two verses and why two
different words are used. Thank you in
advance for answering my question.
Okay, I think it will be important to
read those two verses so that we can
then uh sort of u compare and see where
these apparent two different words are
found. Uh the first verse Genesis 2:7 it
says, "And the Lord God formed men of
the dust of the ground and bre breathed
into his nostrils the breath of life and
man became a living being."
Now let's go into the book of
Ecclesiastes. Then the dust will return
to the earth as it was
>> and the spirit will return to God who
gave it.
>> So uh just for context or context the
verse that just I just read
12:7 the word ruach that she's
mentioning is the word that it's
mentioned here as spirit as that that
will returns to God. Mhm.
>> Now the word that she mentions there
nephesh in Genesis 2:7
is the word that is in this version of
the Bible translated as living being.
The word or in other translations is
called living soul. So um now pastor B I
know you have done a a huge study on
this particular subject. So maybe you
can lead us into the difference and why
perhaps they are not uh these two words
that she's come she's saying they're the
same thing are actually not the same
thing particularly
>> okay I want to take this opportunity to
mention that I have study notes on uh
the state of the dead uh these are not
the usual basically the purpose is to
study those difficult texts that are
misinterpreted frequently about the
state of the dead
>> so uh this has 24 chapters and um so
let's talk first of all about uh the
word spirit.
>> There are two Hebrew words that usually
are translated breath or spirit.
>> One of those is the word ruak which uh
she mentions in her in her question.
Mhm.
>> Uh but ruach and the other word are
synonymous basically.
>> And uh the evidence of that and I have
several texts here, but I'm only going
to read one. Job 33:4.
Uh here Job says, "The spirit, the ruach
of God has made me
>> and the breath, the nama
of the almighty gives me life." Mhm.
>> So here this is a synonymous parallelism
which is the main characteristic of
Hebrew poetry.
>> The first line is repeated in the second
line in different words.
>> Yes.
>> So the the spirit of God has made me is
the same as the breath of the almighty
gives me life.
>> Mhm.
>> So what then is the nama or what is the
ruach? It's the breath of life.
>> Yes.
>> It's the power that gives you the
ability to breathe.
>> Yes.
>> That keeps your body alive. Amen.
>> In other words, that's the word spirit.
>> By the way, the word uh spirit in the
New Testament means the same thing.
>> Uh James 2:26, a famous verse uh only in
the New Testament. It's not the word
ruach or nama in the New Testament, it's
the word panuma.
>> The same word that is translated holy
spirit.
>> Correct. Uh here James says for as the
body without the spirit which is the
breath
>> is dead. So faith without works is dead
also. So in the New Testament the word
panuma is equivalent to nama or ruach in
the old testament.
>> Okay.
>> And basically it's the breath that
energizes the body.
>> Yeah. I have it down as a lifegiving
attribute of God.
>> Right.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh and the word soul is different.
um in Genesis 2 and:e 7 uh you know that
has is translated living soul in the
King James living being in the New King
James
>> um basically and means a per a living
person
>> that's what the word soul means
>> but it is the combination
of the breath of life and the body of
dust
>> that makes up the soul it became a
living soul so Man doesn't have a soul.
>> Yes.
>> Man is a soul.
>> Which is the body and the breath.
>> Exactly.
>> In Genesis 2:7, we actually see the
process of dust plus breath
equals living soul or nephesh. The word
that that our sister is asking about
>> again dust plus breath which is those
combination equals the word fesh or
living soul or living being. In
Ecclesiastes 12:7 you have the word ruah
which is breath returns and dust returns
to the great to this to the earth and
that equals death. So we have in a sense
we have the emphasis of those two verses
is is contrary. The first one is
composition. What composite you know
what composes the human being become a
living being while in the other one is a
reversal process. What happens from a
person that is alive goes to the grave.
[clears throat] And so uh just just to
keep it clear uh for our sister Lara,
nephesh is not the same word as ruach is
not is not breathing is not the breath
of God is the result of the breath of
God plus the dust of the earth.
>> Right? I think that's that that's the
key and you both have have hit on it.
One is a composite entity. The these two
words are not at war with each other. Uh
one is talking about the totality. Yeah.
and one is talking about one of the
elements that make up that totality. So
it is an element of the totality that
goes back to God. So the totality no
longer exists. When you bring the
animating power of God and the inanimate
dust of the ground, you get
>> a composite soul.
>> Take away either of those uh
>> parts or pieces or facets or elements,
you get uh uh uh the inanimate dust and
the breath going back to God. And you
know the problem is sometimes with the
inconsistency in the translations.
>> Yes.
>> For example, the the King James version
sometimes translates the word nephesh as
persons.
>> Mhm.
>> Yes.
>> Because the nephesh is the person. For
example, uh in Genesis 12:5, it says,
"Then Abram took Sarah, his wife, and
Lot, his brother's son, and all their
possessions that they had gathered, and
the people whom they had acquired in
Herod." [clears throat]
>> That is the same word,
>> nephesh.
>> You know, we use the word souls. We say,
"Oh, that poor soul." What does that
mean? We're talking about their soul
inside of them. No,
>> we say, "I baptized 15 souls." Well, I
don't ever remember baptizing any
intangible thing, you know. I'm I'm
baptizing persons. Yeah.
>> Here's another example. Deuteronomy
12:33.
Only be sure that you do not eat the
blood, for the blood is the life
nephesh. [snorts]
>> You may not eat the life nephesh with
the meat. So here the King James is
correctly translating
>> the word nephesh as life.
>> Yes. Because a person is a living
person, correct? Just like Genesis 2:7
says,
>> Yeah.
>> uh the problem many times is with the
inconsistency.
>> And now I'm going to say something that
some people probably are not going to
very be very happy about. And that is
that the King James version is
problematic when it comes to the state
of the dead.
>> Yeah. Um because because it's reflecting
the biases that existed in the times of
the King James translation.
>> Precisely.
>> And I know some people are going to
argue with me. They're going to say,
"No, it has to be the King James. King
James is perfect."
>> Uh the King James we need to remember is
a translation from the originals.
>> And some of the biases of the
translators came into the text. Um you
know the new new international version
um actually translates
um with a personal pronoun
uh the word soul.
>> Let me give you several examples here um
where Jesus says you will not leave my
soul in hell in the King James
>> u the the NIV says you will not leave me
>> because the soul is me.
>> Um you know fear came upon every soul.
Acts 2 verse 43 and uh the NIV says fear
came upon everyone. [laughter]
Um you have Romans 2:9 where it says
tribulation and anguish upon every soul
who does evil.
>> The NIV says upon every human being who
does evil and I have a whole bunch of
examples here. Let me just recompare a
parable of Jesus in the uh New King
James and in the NIV.
And I will say this is a person who who
accumulated a lot of wealth and kept on
building bigger barns.
>> Yes.
>> And I will say to my soul, that's
>> soul, you have many goods laid up for
many years. Take your ease, eat, drink,
and be merry. But God said to him,
"Fool, this not your soul will be
required of you. Then whose will those
things be to which you have provided? So
is he who lays up treasure for himself
and is not rich toward God."
>> That word himself. So it's translated
soul, soul, soul.
>> Mhm.
>> And then the same word in the New King
James says himself.
>> Himself. Why not translate the whole
thing
>> with himself? Now, here's the NIV.
And I'll say to myself,
>> to my soul, to myself,
>> you the word soul uh not not soul, but
you have plenty of good things laid up
for many years. Take life easy. Eat,
drink, and be merry. But God said to
him, "You fool, this very night your
life will be demanded from you." So the
soul is a life.
>> It's the result of body of of of dust,
the breath which gives a person a life.
>> Uh so the problem many times is with
that tremendous inconsistency
in the translations. Um another text
which I might mention uh the the word
hell.
>> Mhm. You know, in Psalm 16:10, which is
a messianic prophecy, it gives
Adventists all sorts of troubles because
here Jesus is speaking prophetically and
he's saying, "You will not leave my soul
in hell."
>> That's a real problem for Adventists.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, also the soul of Jesus went to
hell when he died. No,
>> the NIV translates, "You will not leave
me in the grave."
>> In a grave.
>> So much simpler. that doesn't complicate
things.
>> So in a sense we can understand that
a lot of these text can be misunderstood
because we're not um sometimes
understanding it clearly because the
translation could be a little bias in
the terminology that they have used
>> and we're not necessarily discarding one
versus the other. We're just presenting
the truth that
a lot of these texts can be a little
difficult because the way they were
translated under the influence of the
translators of the time
>> and so there's no perfect Bible but as
you search the scriptures God will give
you the understanding to understanding
and I I should say it's not perfect
Bible Bible is the perfect word of God
but there is there's issues of
translation that you have to be uh
considered in your studies and God will
lead you to the truth. I think this
highlights the difference, gentlemen,
between Bible reading and Bible study,
>> right?
>> All of the gold is not on the surface.
>> Sometimes you got to mine it. You got to
dig down to get it. Uh there are some
problems. Now, we are not undermining
the King James version. We're not saying
it's a bad version.
>> It's a good version.
>> It's a good version. We're just saying
that there are some problems to to it
that you have to go a layer deeper if
you want to get the understanding,
right? And there are and that's why uh
you know, we've got three computers
here. Bible Hub is such a handy tool
because it gives you eight, 10, 12, a
dozen or more different translations and
you can look at the burden and then
right alongside you can you can actually
do your research. So, uh if you're a
King James person, keep on reading the
King James, but um it may be good to add
some other translations also so that you
get a a little broader picture of uh of
of of what you're trying to study. And
if you see everybody on this side and
the King James over here, then maybe you
ought to ask some questions of the King
James, right? And why do I got 10 here
and only two spies giving me this? You
know, need to look at the dissonance
there and study. And it's good for Bible
study, good for your spiritual growth.
>> Another example of a biased translation
is the thief on the cross. Mhm.
>> If you believe that the soul of man
lives on after death, then you're going
to translate that verse where Jesus said
where Jesus says, "Verily, verily I say
unto you, uh today
>> uh you will be
>> today you will be
>> today
>> you will be with me in paradise."
>> Correct.
>> That's the bias translation because we
know that we know that Jesus didn't go
to paradise that day.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> How can they say that he went to hell
and he went to paradise the same day?
See, it's it's ridiculous. So it's much
better uh where you place the comma.
Yes.
>> Right. Verily verily I say unto you
>> today.
>> Today you will be in paradise. That's
one way. The other is verily verily I
say unto you today you will be in the
future with me in paradise.
>> And only the second translation fits the
biblical evidence.
>> Amen.
>> Very very good. Very well said. Um,
thank you again for that question. Um,
had to do a little research to get
through it, Laura. Thank you so very
much. Hopefully, it is clear to you and
you have an understanding of what uh uh
the Bible is saying. Let's
>> could I just make one comment because I
don't want people to misunderstand.
>> I am not recommending the NIV in
everything because the NIV changes where
it's follows a different manuscript
trail. Mhm.
>> It follows the it follows the the text
that comes from siedicas and vaticanas
and so on whereas the other uh follows
another uh trail of manuscripts. So I'm
not saying that I recommend everything
in the NIV. Um but what I am saying is
that we need to compare versions and you
know you can you can discover things
even if you don't know Greek and Hebrew
today there's Bible software. Oh yes,
>> that can help you do study. U so I'm not
saying the NIV is a perfect version. No,
it takes passages out. It changes words.
It deletes words. I'm aware of that. And
uh in that case, you know, we go to the
King James.
>> But uh but we need to be uh comparative
in our study.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> And remember also that language is
dynamic. It is not static.
>> Right.
>> Once something is written down, you need
to ask yourself who wrote it?
>> What did they say? Mhm.
>> What did they mean? What did the people
who heard him mean,
>> right?
>> Put those three things in the pot and
then you can say what it means to us
today. And if you you cut through that
and make shortcuts, you probably are
going to come out a little bit left of
center. So you need to keep that in your
mind. Let's see if we can get to in the
last few minutes that remain to us
Robert's question from South Africa. Um
>> Pastor Salazar, would you read the
question for us?
>> Absolutely. It says here,
[clears throat] "Marnatha, secrets
unsealed. I used to be under the
impression that the fulfillment of
Ezekiel 96 happened when the Babylonian
Babylonians under the reign of
Nebuchadnezzar went and captured
Jerusalem and killed Yan and all
people." That's because I heard Pastor
Steven Boore saying so in one of his
lectures.
But someone had just corrected me and
showed me a quotation from Ellen White
that states clearly that the fulfillment
will be in the future with God's people.
Is there a quotation where she also
states categorically that the
fulfillment was also historical and was
fulfilled by the Babylonians?
>> Now, pastor, I want to sort of toss this
in your lap because they're saying
they're referencing a statement that you
allegedly made. So, um [clears throat]
you get the opportunity to to clear the
record uh if you can. Ellen White uses
uh Ezekiel chapter 9
>> verse six
>> in both ways.
>> She uses uh Ezekiel 9 to talk about uh
God's people who were faithful within
the city that were not destroyed when
King Nebuchadnezzar came and destroyed
the city. And she also uses this to
refer to end time events where God's
people will be sealed. they will be
protected uh and the other group will be
destroyed. Um what principle do we have
here? We have the principle of type and
anti-ype.
>> We find the passage that in Ezekiel is a
historical event.
>> Yeah,
>> it happened that way.
>> You know, there was a ceiling of the
faithful. They did not perish when
Nebuchadnezzar came and destroyed the
city. They were spared. They were
protected. Mhm.
>> That's historical.
>> Yes.
>> However, historical uh events many times
are used typologically.
>> Yes.
>> And in Revelation chapter 7, you have
the typological application. In in
Ezekiel chapter 9, you have a mark on
the forehead.
>> In Revelation chapter 7, you have a seal
on the forehead. Mhm.
>> So you know that what happened with
literal Babylon locally in the Old
Testament now becomes global at the end
of time.
>> So So the question basically says that
uh suggests that he was corrected uh
because he showed him um an Ellen White
quotation that says the fulfillment is
in the future. But Ellen White also
applies this historically to what
happened in the past.
>> Uh so so there's no contradiction. It's
just you're dealing with typology.
>> Uh agree so very very very much. Um I've
got the same list here. Type seal two
classes executive judgment from easy9
but they since they reference your name
and and refer a statement that you had
said allegedly wanted to give you a
chance to to straighten that up. David,
do you have anything to add to that?
Well, it's it's important when we study
the scriptures and we look into quotes
that are in the spirit prophecy. Um, we
also do the part of of doing our own
research. Don't take somebody's word. Go
to the scriptures, analyze the content
of scripture. In this case, as you will
said, pastor,
>> this is the prophecy of Ezekiel, which
was uh, you know, parallel with
Jeremiah. They were prophets of the same
time period. They were pro pre
projecting or prophesying what would
happen as the Babylonians would come and
the Lord had his faithful among Daniel
among them and and his friends. They
were faithful who had going to were
going to be spared by the Lord in spite
of the destruction that was coming. And
so I mean even Jeremiah himself and and
the prophets Ezekiel and all these
people were protected from destruction.
They were they were spared. And so this
verse is not necessarily only applicable
to uh their time as it was said but also
has a parallelism as a as the event in
the last day you know time when we will
be sealed those that are the faithful
will have the seal of God and will be
protected from destruction and death
because they have received the sealing
of God in their foreheads. So it's
really just understanding how this verse
can be applicable for the past and for
the future.
>> Yeah. And you find this over and over
again. There are many things that have
their actual uh reality in what
happened, but it is a type of something
that will happen in the future,
including the fall of Jerusalem.
>> Sure. Uh the same.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. Uh any last word
you want to get in, pastor, before we
>> Well, just remember we have the study
notes on the state of the dead. I would
recommend that uh you you get this
material
>> because it's going to really really be a
blessing in answering some of those
texts that people use that are out of
context or because of mistransations or
so on.
>> Amen.
>> All righty, we are coming to the closing
seconds of our program. We hope this
program has been a blessing to you. It
certainly has been to us. Our time has
fast lifted into eternity. Allow me to
close to with you both grace and truth
through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.